- [Zac] Originally from California,
Billy Hargrove was born
in 1967... in California.
The city - in California
- that Billy grew up in
is never mentioned, but it's most likely
somewhere in Southern California,
based on Billy's penchant for surfing.
In California.
DUSTIN: Yeah, totally tubular.
What, did I say that right?
Or is it like tubular?
(elongates the pronunciation)
- [Zac] The name of Billy's birth mother
remains unknown,
but what is known is that Billy
would have been very close
to her as a small child.
Billy's happiest memory
is from when he was about
seven or eight years old.
He was surfing, while his
mother cheered him on.
Billy brags about surfing a
wave that was seven feet tall.
His Mom says she saw it
and he almost gave her a heart attack.
Billy asks if he can keep
surfing for 10 more minutes,
and his Mom reluctantly agrees, saying,
"Any longer than that
and Dad's gonna be mad."
It would be that very fury from
Billy's dad, Neil Hargrove,
that shaped him into who he would become.
To learn more about Billy,
and what makes him one of
Hawkins' scariest antagonists,
stick around to the end of this video.
(metal music)
Welcome to Horror History.
In this episode I'll be
covering the childhood,
life and end of Hawkins'
most intimidating high school student:
Billy Hargrove.
I've mentioned in other
videos on Stranger Things,
that Stephen King is a huge
influence for the show,
from the town of Hawkins
itself to specific characters.
Billy is far from an exception.
The Duffer Brothers, the
creators of "Stranger Things",
cited King directly when
coming up with Billy, stating:
"Stephen King always has
really great human villains.
"The evil in the real
world is often as bad
"or worse than the supernatural evil,
"so we wanted to include
a character like that."
So, it comes as no surprise
that Billy shares a lot of similarities
with some of King's
ugliest child antagonists.
He even shares the same name
as Billy Nolan from Carrie.
But Billy Hargrove possibly
has the most in common
with Henry Bowers from "IT".
From the more than tough fathers,
to their views on those that
are different than them,
and treatment of those they
see as weaker than them,
there are a lot of parallels you can draw.
To fully understand Billy
and what makes him so scary,
I'm gonna take it back to his upbringing.
(mysterious music)
Billy's Dad, Neil, was a
little bit on the tough side,
to say the least.
Billy played baseball as a kid,
on a team called The Tigers.
His Dad was extremely
critical of his performance,
often yelling at him if he didn't perform
up to expectations.
Because of this, Billy
grew up afraid of his Dad,
as did his mother.
NEIL: Where were you last
night? Where were you?
MRS H: I told you! I was with Wendy.
NEIL: Stop lying to me!
MRS H: I'm not lying to you!
Get away from me! I said Get away!"
Neil Hargrove went on to re-marry,
giving Billy a new step-mom
and a step-sister named Maxine.
Billy is full of anger and resentment
towards this new family.
It was never his fault that
his parents got divorced
and now he's being asked
to accept this new family
with open arms?
Maxine often finds herself
on the receiving end
of Billy's teenage angst.
In October of 1984, when
Billy was seventeen years old,
Neil moves the family to Hawkins, Indiana.
Hawkins has the feeling
of a Stephen King town
in that it is frightening
for the kids that live there,
because they not only have
to deal with the Upside Down,
Demogorgons and the Mind Flayer,
but there are also a
multitude of human monsters
to look out for.
On October 28th, 1984
Billy's parents force him
to drive Max to school
and their resentment
for each other is clear,
based on how Max slams
the door and storms off
on the first day of their
respective new schools.
(heavy metal music plays)
Billy drives a blue Camaro,
not unlike the blue muscle car
seen in the Muschietti adaptation of IT
driven around by the Bowers gang.
He even has the look of several
of Stephen King's bully characters.
The jeans, boots, even style of shirt,
is similar to Ace
Merrill from Stand By Me.
This is a very specific choice
in that Billy both demonstrates
a popular look and trend
of the early 80s, but also could pass
as an Ace Merrill type from the 60s.
This look is what draws
the attention of everyone.
- Who is that?
- I have no idea but would
you check out that butt?
Just look at it go.
- [Zac] The women of Hawkins
may be awestruck by Billy,
and he repeatedly puts himself on display
for this kind of attention.
But in another parallel to Ace Merrill,
Billy has no respect for women
and he makes that abundantly clear.
- You smell that Max. That's
actually (beep). Cow (beep).
- I don't see any cows.
- Clearly, you haven't
met the high school girls.
- [Zac] Yikes!
Another commonality he shares with Ace
can be seen in one of the
most tense scenes in the film,
which is not featured in the
novella that inspired it.
Ace plays chicken with an
oncoming log truck to win a race.
He shows absolute determination,
and no fear or concern at
the possibility of killing
everyone in the car, despite
their pleas for him to stop.
Stranger Things has a moment
that looks almost identical.
On Halloween, Billy
torments Max by threatening
to run Will, Lucas and
Dustin off of the road,
never letting up,
with the same unrelenting
determination as Ace.
(wheels squeal)
- Yeah! That was a close one, huh?
- [Zac] But Max, Will, Dustin and Lucas
are not the only ones to end
up in Billy's crosshairs.
Billy likes attention and
draws a lot of it himself.
This is evident in the way he dresses,
the way he revs his engine
upon pulling into the school
and I could go on.
So, when Billy hears that Steve Harrington
is the most popular guy
at Hawkins High School,
he immediately perceives Steve
as someone he needs to dominate.
And what better place for a
legendary rivalry to begin,
than that year's Halloween party?
(crowd cheering)
(mysterious music)
Billy's quest to overtake
Steve's reputation
begins at the big Halloween party,
where Billy infiltrates
Steve's friend group
by beating Steve's record at keg stands,
impressing Steve's friends.
TOMMY: We got ourselves a
new Keg King, Harrington.
- Yeah, that's right.
- Yeah, eat it, Harrington.
- [Zac] Apparently in Hawkins,
all you have to do to get a
group of friends to drop one
is be really good at
chugging beer upside down.
But Billy's determination
to dominate Steve Harrington
doesn't stop there.
The next day the two
have gym class together,
where Billy repeatedly
makes verbal jabs at him
and even aggressively knocks him down,
telling him to plant his
feet better next time.
Man, they're playing like
it's the 90s out there!
Oh yeah, it's still the 80s in this show.
It comes as no surprise that
when, just a few days later,
Billy overhears that
Nancy, Steve's girlfriend,
was seen ditching school with another guy.
Billy takes this as another
opportunity to emasculate Steve.
BILLY: Don't take it too hard man.
A pretty boy like you has
nothing to worry about.
Plenty of (beep) in the sea.
I'll be sure to leave you some.
- [Zac] I can't help but be reminded again
of Ace from Stand by Me.
EYEBALL: So, what's with you
and this Connie Palermo chick?
JACK: Eh, I've been seeing
her for a month now,
and all she'll let me do is feel her tits.
ACE: She's a Catholic man.
If you wanna get laid, you
gotta get yourself a Protestant.
- [Zac] But it's also something
Billy probably picked up from his own Dad.
Neil at one point tells
Billy to cancel a date
with whatever harlot he's seeing tonight.
He used a different word.
Sadly, misogyny is not
the only negative trait
that Billy takes on,
that he likely learned
from Neil Hargrove.
Billy rarely pays attention to anything
his step-sister Max does,
but on November 2nd, 1984,
when Billy notices Max
having a heated discussion
with Lucas Sinclair,
he suddenly takes an
interest in Max's social life
and makes it clear that he disapproves
of her spending time with Lucas.
In fact, of everyone that Billy
interacts with in Hawkins,
it seems like he harbors the
most disdain towards Lucas,
without really knowing anything about him.
The scene kind of made me
wonder if it was a race thing.
- Hey! This is serious (beep) okay?
I'm older than you,
and something you learn
is that there are certain
types of people in this world
that you stay away from.
And that kid, Max.
That kid is one of them.
- [Zac] The actor, Dacre Montgomery,
has stated that Billy's real
reason for not liking Lucas
has more to do with Lucas
seeming to have a crush on Max.
"He loves his sister Max,
"and if it were any
other kid bothering her
"he would have reacted the same way."
It's kind of a strange answer,
because Billy hasn't been shown
to care about his
step-sister up to this point,
and he doesn't share the
same attitude for Dustin,
who also shows interest in Max.
But if Billy's feeling towards Lucas
are partially race related,
it would be another parallel to the way
that Henry Bowers treats and
thinks of Mike Hanlon in IT.
In the case of Henry Bowers,
the racism is directly
learned from his Dad.
And even if Billy isn't racist,
he definitely picked up
some prejudiced views
from his own father.
Unfortunately for Max,
she has a second interaction
like this with Billy
the very next day. In
addition to being forced
to take Max to and from school,
it's also Billy's
responsibility to pick her up
from the arcade.
Max tries to keep Billy
from being able to see
that she had been talking to Lucas,
but Billy still catches them.
BILLY: What the hell did I tell you?
MAX: It's a small town,
okay? We weren't hanging out.
BILLY: You know what happens when you lie.
- [Zac] Even this warning about lying
comes from the influence of Neil Hargrove.
When Billy was growing up,
Neil Hargrove would accuse
Billy's mother of lying
and there were consequences
when he thought she was.
Apparently in this case,
the consequence for Max
is a broken skateboard.
Billy's warning does not
fall on deaf ears with Max,
however, she doesn't
communicate this to Lucas.
And who can really blame her?
What would that conversation look like?
It's easier for her to
just not mention it.
As I mentioned, one of
Billy's defining traits
is his love for attention.
He's very focused on his appearance,
so he's often working out,
yet smoking as he does so,
which kind of defeats the purpose.
I bet he would get along with Kat
from Final Destination 2.
But, despite taking smoke
directly into his lungs while working out,
his work is apparently so profuse,
that he refuses to be interrupted
when the doorbell rings.
Max abruptly shuts the door,
so Billy can tell something is up,
sending him to drop his
work out and investigate.
But only after also cracking open a beer?
It feels like everything this guy does
is counterproductive to his workout.
I mean, I would go on further about this,
but I've actually seen people drinking
sugar filled energy drinks at the gym.
Maybe these people are just so powerful
that they have to set
themselves back a little bit
to give the rest of us a chance.
Or maybe they're just fu-
BILLY: Who the hell were you talking to?
MAX: Mormons.
- Mormons?
- Talkative ones.
- [Zac] After this, he leaves her to it,
but when Billy's Dad and Step-Mom
come home later that night,
they notice Max is missing
and Neil blames Billy
for not watching her.
NEIL: So that's why you've
been staring at yourself
in the mirror like some (beep)
instead of watching your sister?
- You had one job Billy!
I think Neil also has a lot in common
with Webby Garton, from IT.
Webby was part of the gang responsible
for the death of a gay
man named Adrian Melon.
I analyzed the whole situation
in Adrian's own episode of Horror History.
Neil seems to have the
same heterosexist outlook,
which may have rubbed off on his son.
Just one of the many weird, just weird,
messed up issues that Billy seems to have.
And another would soon make itself known.
(mysterious music)
Billy's Dad sends him to
find his missing step-sister,
and while going from door to door,
he makes a stop at the Wheeler
house to see if Max is there,
allowing him to have this
statutory exchange with Mike
and Nancy's Mom, Karen Wheeler.
- Oh, hi.
- Hi.
- I didn't realize that
Nancy had a sister.
- I'm Nancy's mother.
- No.
- Yes.
- Mrs. Wheeler.
- I'm sorry, and you are?
- Billy. Billy Hargrove.
- You must be here for Nancy.
- Nancy? No, not my type.
- [Zac] Well, honestly
he kinda dodged a bullet there.
After Billy gets the information
he needs from Mrs. Wheeler,
he moves on to the Byers' house.
As usual Billy wants all eyes
on him and he revs his engine.
This has the desired effect
and Max starts to panic,
saying that Billy will kill
her and probably everyone else,
if he realizes she's there.
It's up to Steve
Harrington to divert Billy
away from the house,
so he goes outside to confront him.
Once again, Billy does his best
to assert dominance over his new rival.
- This whole situation, Harrington.
I don't know. It's giving
me the heebie jeebies.
- Oh yeah? Why's that?
- My 13 year old sister
goes missing all day,
and then I find her with
you, in a stranger's house,
and you lie to me about it.
- [Zac] Kind of a bold statement
for a teenager who just
told a much older woman
that a girl his own age is not his type.
But Billy does manage to once again
assert dominance over Steve,
by hitting him so hard
he's knocked to the ground,
citing again that Steve
should have planted his feet.
Considering that Billy
seems threatened by Steve,
you'd think Steve would be
the main target of his anger,
but Billy's real anger comes out at Lucas
and it is truly terrifying.
BILLY: Well, well, well. Lucas
Sinclair, what a surprise.
I thought I told you to
stay away from him, Max.
- Billy, go away.
- You disobeyed me.
And you what happens when you disobey me?
- Billy-
- I break things.
- [Zac] But luckily for Lucas,
Steve Harrington isn't done.
Just when it seems like Lucas
might be in real trouble,
Steve unexpectedly grabs Billy,
managing to at least
redirect Billy's rage.
As Steve lies helpless on the ground
after being pummeled by Billy,
Max notices a syringe left
over from the Hawkins lab
and injects the contents into his neck.
And honestly, it's not completely clear
that Max even knew what
was in the syringe.
Aside from the possibility
that it's something completely dangerous
and she could have been responsible
for whatever happened to him,
what if it was some kind of steroid
that would have just made
him stronger and more angry?
Or what if it caused him to slowly
turn into Grimace from the
McDonald's commercials?
It could have been really, really bad.
But luckily, it's just a tranquilizer,
so Billy woke up a few hours later
in the locker room of the
Hawkins pool and heard
- [Jigsaw] I want to play a game.
- No, I'm kidding.
As the sedative takes effect,
instead of getting scared or even angry,
he starts laughing, which
is much more creepy.
As he collapses to the floor,
she delivers more than a stern warning
for Billy to leave her
and her friends alone.
He doesn't object as
his younger step-sister
proceeds to steal his car,
and pretty much leaves
Lucas alone after that
and lays low throughout the
next year at Hawkins High.
But Billy, always vying
to be in the public eye,
doesn't stay out of it for long.
In the Summer of 1985,
he gets a job as a
lifeguard at the local pool.
- Lol.
Karen Wheeler is no longer
the only adult woman in Hawkins
to take an interest in Billy.
- Ladies, she's coming down.
- (sexy music plays)
- [Zac] However, Karen may be
the only woman whose
interest seems to be mutual.
She purposely swims when
she knows he's watching
and he takes the bait,
inviting her to meet him
at a hotel at nights for swimming lessons.
Which makes me wonder, I mean
they're already at a pool.
Why don't they just do
swimming lessons right he-
Oh, he's talking about se-
As Billy drives to the hotel,
his car hits something in the road.
Unfortunately, it wasn't Nancy,
or Lucas's little sister.
In fact, it doesn't seem to be anything.
As he gets out, he is pulled
by another powerful creature
from the Upside-Down,
the Mind Flayer, into the
Brimborn Steelworks Warehouse,
where it's able to occupy Billy,
similar to what it did to
Will Byers the previous year.
Unlike Will though,
Billy has a direct conversation
with the Mind Flayer,
which communicates with Billy
by giving him visions
of talking to himself.
BILLY: I said, what do you want?
FLAYED BILLY: To build.
I want you to build.
- To build what?
- What you see.
- I don't understand.
- In an interview with the New York Times,
Dacre Montgomery gave a little
bit of additional context:
For Flayed Billy, I did a lot of research
on bipolar disorder and
split personalities,
and how one personality controls
the other personalities.
- [Zac] Yes, I'm aware
that bipolar and dissociative
identity disorder
are not the same thing,
but feel free to leave 100 comments
telling me about it anyways.
This direct conversation with himself
could be seen as a symbol for a struggle
with multiple mental health
issues, but this video,
I'll just focus on the one that seems
to be most persistent in
Stranger Things season 3:
bipolar disorder.
He experiences all of the common traits
of someone being inhabited
by the Mind Flayer,
which makes Billy act in stark
contrast to his usual self.
He is sensitive to light,
his skin literally burns
at being in the sun.
This causes Billy to become an introvert
and someone who wants to avoid being seen.
Definitely not the
Billy we've come to know
up to this point.
According to the Mayo Clinic,
different variations of
bipolar disorder involve
what are called manic episodes.
At times, the person may
be abnormally upbeat,
jumpy or wired, having increased activity,
an exaggerated sense of well-being
and heightened self-confidence.
But on the other side, there
are major depressive episodes
that include marked loss of interest,
feeling no pleasure in activities,
restlessness or slowed behavior,
feelings of worthlessness,
and decreased ability
to think or concentrate.
Many of these traits show
themselves in "flayed Billy."
When he returns to work, he's
sluggish and doesn't seem
to like anyone noticing him.
He even hides away in a back
room to avoid the public.
This is even more evident
when Karen follows Billy
into the backroom and
attempts to apologize
for standing him up.
Billy can't even bring
himself to look at her
and feels compelled to hurt her,
as he has a vision where he
slams her head into a wall.
KAREN: I shouldn't have said that--
SLAAAAAMMIN'!!!!
He exerts enough self
control to not do that
and instead, leaves
Karen with a firm warning
to stay away from him.
To this point, it seems
like Billy is going through
much of what Will went
through when he was occupied
by the Mind Flayer a year prior,
but this would soon change,
as the Mind Flayer realizes
a unique opportunity
that its new subject presents.
Under the influence of
the massive entity of the Upside-Down,
Billy Hargrove is compelled to
bring other Hawkins residents
to the warehouse for the Mind
Flayer to occupy them, too.
One victim of this would
be a fellow lifeguard
named Heather Holloway.
FARNSWORTH: Go to hell Heather!
- [Zac] The next day
at the lifeguard chair,
Billy literally starts to burn up,
so he runs to the showers
to stand in the cold water,
and Heather runs after
him to see if he is okay,
but the Mind Flayer
lives up to it's namesake
and distorts his perception of the events.
- Take me to him!
- [Zac] Which he does.
After knocking her out cold,
he lays her down at the steel works
and tells her not to be afraid
and that it'll soon all be over.
- Don't be afraid. It'll be over soon.
(thumps)
(screams)
- I think she might be afraid.
After she joins the Mind Flayers ranks,
the two of them continue to
act like normal residents
as not to raise suspicion,
by filling the bathtub
with bags and bags of ice
to keep their body temperatures cool.
The next targets are Heather's parents.
When Eleven and Max, who realize
something is up with Billy,
arrive at the Holloway's house,
Billy is no longer
acting sluggish and shy.
He's upbeat, outgoing, and talkative.
The Mind Flayer is active and
Billy is exhibiting traits
of a common manic episode. As
soon as Eleven and Max leave,
only partially convinced by
Billy's seemingly innocent act,
Billy and Heather team up to
knock out Mr. and Mrs Holloway
and take them to the Brimborn Steel Works
and give the same warning.
HEATHER: It'll all be over soon.
- [Zac] At one point, Will
shares his experiences
of being possessed by the
Mind Flayer with his friends,
stating that those who are possessed
are kind of themselves
until the Mind Flayer
becomes active, a pattern that
seems to support my theory
that the creature's grip
on Billy is an allegory
for a manic or depressive
episode of bipolar disorder.
I also find it interesting
that the kids make a plan
to draw the Mind Flayer out of Billy
by locking him in a sauna, as
the Mind Flayer hates heat.
Literally bipolar. Their
plan almost even works,
as Billy is burning up in the
sauna he, for the first time,
shares vulnerability
with his step sister Max,
screaming repeatedly, "It's not my fault"
and "He made me do it."
Again, according to the
Mayo Clinic and other sites,
it's a common trait for
someone experiencing mania
to engage in reckless and
even compulsive behavior
they later regret.
When Max asks "Who made you do it?,"
Billy describes the Mind
Flayer as a giant shadow.
Something that he can't articulate
and that is beyond his control.
As Billy and Max share this moment
and Max explains to Billy that
they are trying to help him,
The Mind Flayer interrupts by
becoming "active" once again,
and Billy smashes the
glass door of the sauna
and lashes out at the kids.
Eleven, with her psychokinetic powers,
is just barely able to save them,
but the battle seems to
use up most of her power.
Billy meets up with
Heather shortly after this.
- [Heather] The girl, was it her?
- [Billy] Yeah. It was her. She knows now.
She knows about me. She
could have killed me.
- [Zac] Wait a minute. Aren't they both
under the control of the
Mind Flayer right here?
Like the Mind Flayer is just having
this conversation with itself?
I guess maybe how this works
is everything they know
is sent to the Mind
Flayer, but the Mind Flayer
doesn't necessarily send
information back to them.
It may be for a good reason,
seeing as how Eleven is capable
of going into their heads,
which she does, shortly after.
She sees Billy's most intimate memories.
How happy he was with
his mother on the beach
and how disturbing his father was.
This goes on until the Mind
Flayer becomes active again,
trapping Eleven in Billy's
head and taunting her
that it's coming for her.
- And now it's time. Time to end it.
And we are going to end you.
- Eleven is able to fight back and escape,
but The Mind Flayer
now has enough strength
to leave Brimborn Steelworks Warehouse
and go after her itself. So it sends Billy
to track her and try to find her,
but he finds himself just one
step behind wherever she goes.
Billy finally gets to
her after The Mind Flayer
finds Eleven on it's own and he shows up.
The kids are trying to
escape from Starcourt Mall.
In an attempt to intimidate
them he revs his engine.
This may seem like the
old Billy, but it isn't.
Billy is now completely
overtaken by the Mind Flayer
and floors it at Nancy, who
fires a gun directly at him,
but apparently misses him.
But Billy's old nemesis, Steve
Harrington saves the day.
Billy is badly hurt but still manages
to catch Mike and Max trying
to escape with Eleven.
He's completely lost
control at this point,
throwing his own step sister
and Mike against a wall
and hitting Eleven's head
so hard he knocks her out.
He takes Eleven up to the food court
to present her to The Mind Flayer,
just as he had with Heather, her family
and likely several others,
but Eleven is able to connect
with him on a human level
by bringing up the memories
that he shared with her.
- Seven feet.
You told her the wave was seven feet.
And you... you were happy.
- In California!
It seems that Eleven has managed
to break through the
barrier in Billy's mind
and speak to the real Billy.
After this moment of human connection,
Billy leaves El alone and stands up
to confront the Mind Flayer.
Using his bare hands,
he's actually able to
hold the monster off,
to protect Max and her friends.
But he's only able to
withstand it for so long.
The other appendages of this
terrifying creature jut out
and latch onto him,
rendering him immobile,
before finally one of its
arms shoots through his chest
and finishes him. Given the highs and lows
Billy was put through by this creature,
his fate could be allegory
for a losing battle with mental illness.
His last words are to his sister Max,
- I'm sorry.
- [Zac] This moment of overcoming
an evil supernatural entity
that's possessing him
and letting love for family
override everything, briefly,
leading to a self sacrifice
sounds very similar
to Jack Torrance in The Shining:
The face in front of him
changed. It was hard to say how;
there was no melting or
merging of the features.
The body trembled slightly,
and then the bloody hands
opened like broken claws.
The mallet fell from them
and thumped on the rug.
That was all. But suddenly
his Daddy was there,
looking at him in mortal agony,
and sorry so great that Danny's heart
flamed within his chest.
The mouth drew down in a quivery bow.
"Doc," Jack Torrance
said. "Run away quick.
And remember how much I love you."
That's not just a coincidence.
The Duffer brothers instructed
actor Dacre Montgomery
to specifically draw from Jack Torrance.
- I was given a lot of
Jack Nicholson, yeah,
a lot of like The Shining.
Because my character, I think,
in many ways, is kind of that
unpredictable sort of nature
that I think Jack Nicholson, sort of has.
- I find it fitting that
Billy, who seems to be
a melting pot of many of Stephen King's
greatest human villains,
ends his story in such a similar way
to perhaps the most iconic human villain
that King has ever created.
Despite being an awful
person for most of the story,
I think a lot of viewers find
his death to be a tragic one,
given how young he was, and of course,
his late stage redemption arc.
And this isn't canon, but the next day,
Mrs. Wheeler cried for 14 hours,
lamenting in having missed her chance.
If you want to see the histories
of more Stranger Things characters,
click that playlist on the left.
I've got at least one
more episode on the way,
so remember to subscribe to CZsWorld
for new horrors every week,
ring the death bell for all notifications
and I'll see you in the next
one. Assuming we both survive.
(techno music plays)